if you're a fan of christopher nolan's
2014
sci-fi space epic interstellar you'll
probably want to watch it more than once
to make sure that you get
everything out of it so let's transcend
space and time once again as we discover
the details that are only clear after
multiple viewings
the convergence point for the entire
decade spanning story and interstellar
is murphy's childhood bedroom
there's a poltergeist chucking books off
her bookshelf
and toying with the physics of gravity
and magnetism ten-year-old murphy played
by mackenzie foy doesn't appear to be
afraid of the apparition
instead she's mostly curious luckily
she's being raised by a father with a
scientific mind who has no room for
superstition
cooper played by matthew mcconaughey
instructs his daughter to not just
label it as a ghost because she doesn't
know what it is
instead he directs her to study it and
come to a scientific conclusion her
instincts end up being accurate all
along and her first
line of dialogue hints at the final
outcome the opening moments of
interstellar feature a brief tumultuous
moment from cooper's days as a pilot
his aircraft spins out of control and
the g's amp up before he suddenly snaps
awake safely at home in his bed
standing over him is his daughter who
looks at him and says
i thought you were the ghost later by
the end of the film we find out just how
accurate this statement really is
christopher nolan is fascinated with the
intricacies of time
particularly the paradoxes created by
toying with timelines
interstellar creates scenarios where
time stretches and squeezes based on its
character's galactic locations
they unknowingly trigger various events
that lead them to the nasa base where
cooper signs on to pilot a mission to
save the world
coordinates to this base arrive courtesy
of the ghost in murphy's room
the directions are given in binary form
by altering gravity so billowing dust
settles strategically on the floor
to spell out a message the ghost ends up
being cooper himself from inside the
tesseract within the massive black hole
known as gargantua
but where did this whole chain of events
begin
as we find out later the instructions
for how to find the nasa base were given
to cooper by cooper himself
however in order to get inside the
tesseract and give himself these
directions he needed to have already
received them thus creating a paradox
for which there
is no answer the notion of an
unanswerable question
is very much something that we should
always expect from christopher nolan so
be prepared for your brain to have a
workout whenever you watch one of his
films
once the crew of the endurance travels
through the wormhole into an unknown
galaxy
they receive a clearer picture from the
data sent out by previous explorers on
all the possible planets orbiting
gargantua after some deliberation they
decide to first visit a planet closer to
the black hole
though its proximity to the massive
gravity created by gargantua creates
some problems with relativity
time on this planet runs much faster
than on earth as
every hour is equivalent to seven years
back home
therefore their time must be considered
a precious resource that they do not
have in abundance the whole excursion is
incredibly stressful
and with multiple viewings that's only
amplified especially once you notice the
strange ticking
sound playing in the background the
entire time they're on this first planet
it turns out that there's a reason that
this ominous ticking plays consistently
throughout the scene
one particular cinema sleuth on reddit
discovered that these
ticks occur exactly 1.25 seconds apart
with a little math you can work out that
each tick is equivalent to one entire
earth day
this knowledge adds another whole layer
of stress to an already tense situation
and multiple viewings only peel back
more layers to this odyssey
the most exciting part of any space
adventure obviously occurs once the
characters are out voyaging among the
stars
this quality is likely to leave you
feeling antsy during your first time
watching interstellar plenty of viewers
are probably anxious as the characters
hop
into a rocket ship and launch into space
which could cause many of the most
fascinating elements of the story to
slip by unnoticed
and that's one reason why multiple
viewings are so rewarding as
every bit of dialogue and interstellar
has a purpose since
everything comes full circle for example
cooper's talk with murphy
is a particularly prophetic conversation
that hits harder when you watch it again
before he leaves earth cooper says what
you're a parent you're the ghost of your
children's future
this poetic message winds up becoming
reality in more ways than
one not only does cooper quite literally
end up being the ghost in his daughter's
bedroom
he also in a way becomes a figurative
ghost walking into the hospital room
where murphy is on her deathbed
he's the same age as he was when he left
earth stepping back into his daughter's
life
exactly as he was in her memories a
ghost in her future
the small crew of the endurance isn't
the first group of brave astronauts to
plunge themselves into the wormhole near
saturn
a decade before their mission departed a
group of 12 was sent across the universe
to explore the viability of these new
worlds
each individual was sent to their own
planet to discover the possibilities
due to the potential of death for these
astronauts they were required to not
have any attachments on earth as
explained by amelia brand played by anne
hathaway
while this was a strict prerequisite for
the original mission it apparently
wasn't completely inflexible for the
follow-up
among the endurance crew half of them do
in fact have family attachments
cooper has two kids he desperately wants
to return home to while brand is the
daughter of the lead scientist
the no attachment stipulation of the
first mission was based on the logic
that people would operate with the whole
human race in mind as opposed
to individual desires we're surprised
that this crucial second mission lacked
that same strict guideline
when dr mann sits up in his cryotube
it's a pleasant surprise to discover
that he's played by matt damon
which was kept under wraps before
interstellar hit theaters
that's an understandable decision if we
had known he was in the film ahead of
time we would have been waiting
impatiently for him to show up during
the first half
damon usually plays heroic roles but not
this time
although he's not exactly a villain per
se just more of a cowardly antagonist
man's survival instincts contrast
notably with the rest of the film
at its core interstellar is a tale of
human connection
since the first crew sent into the
wormhole were required to have no family
attachments
man doesn't share the same deep
connections that brandon cooper have
this leaves him purely self-serving he
attempts to mask this quality but
everything he does feels illogical he's
a man operating purely on fear mission
leaders believed that a lack of
attachments would help the crew work
with the greater good in mind but the
opposite turns out to be true as the
only people to survive
either mission are those with
connections back on earth
when cooper is trying to console murphy
before his trip he attempts to appeal to
her intellectual sensibilities by
discussing the fascinating aspects of
time relativity
i mean by the time i get back we might
even be the same age
you and me what
imagine that but this plan backfires
when murphy realizes that her dad has no
idea when he'll actually be returning
from his voyage
she's so upset by this that she doesn't
even send a reply message into space for
more than two decades
the resulting age difference that cooper
predicts does indeed come into play but
it turns out that his estimate
is off by about 60 years cooper
ultimately does make it back to his
daughter
but only in time to witness the final
moments of her life
residents of the cooper space station
inform him that he's 124 earth years old
when he returns
that means he's been gone for more than
80 years which is
quite a long time for a quick reunion
with his daughter
that large chunk of time lost between
the two of them can make their extremely
brief
final interaction a bit anti-climactic
it's a powerful moment but you just
might come away wishing it could have
lasted longer
especially after multiple viewings it's
no secret that christopher nolan is a
big fan
of sir michael kane as the cockney actor
has appeared in almost
every single one of the director's films
in interstellar he plays the lead
scientist at nasa
dr brand his sage-like demeanor helps
convince cooper to embark on his voyage
and a poetic voice-over from kane sets a
majestic tone as the endurance crew
leaves earth
do not go gentle into that good night
once you know the final outcome of this
space odyssey you'll only have more
respect for kane after each viewing
it turns out that dr brand never had any
intention for the successful
execution of plan a which involved
humans leaving earth for a new planet
his formula for harnessing the power of
gravity requires a glimpse at data from
a singularity inside a black hole a
requirement he considered
impossible this means that all the
conversations convincing cooper to join
this mission were laced with a monstrous
lie
knowing this while watching interstellar
more than once will make the nuance of
kane's performance more obvious
he dodges questions and grows distant
when certain topics are brought up and
it's hard
not to be impressed by this legendary
actor even more than you've already been
the main plot twist in interstellar
occurs when it's revealed that dr brand
knew he couldn't complete his gravity
equation the reason is because he needed
information from inside a black hole a
task that was deemed impossible
due to an inability to see beyond the
event horizon
and glimpse the singularity within
luckily for all humanity though
cooper is willing to sacrifice himself
by climbing into a spacecraft and
launching himself into gargantua
once he and his robot companion tars
make it inside he's able to gather
enough data to complete the equation but
then he has to figure out how to get the
information back out
since cooper is trapped behind an
endless stream of bookshelves in
murphy's bedroom the only solution is to
send this information to her
by manipulating gravity from within the
tesseract he's able to relay the data
through morse code
we know that there's plenty of artistic
license taken with interstellar but this
one sticks out
more with each viewing we're not going
to pretend to be math experts but we
feel safe assuming that complex quantum
data about the occurrences inside a
black hole
probably can't be easily transmitted via
morse code in most circumstances
cooper's journey to return to his
daughter dwarfs any distance traveled by
any human in history
unfortunately because of relativity he
returns to find murphy on her deathbed
the nurse at the hospital informs cooper
that she's been in cryosleep for two
years the large amount of family
gathered around her indicates that she's
lived a full life without her dad
she tells him that no one should have to
watch their own child
die so she spurs him onward back into
the cosmos in search of dr amelia brand
but how does she know that she's still
alive she's
out there
[Music]
setting up camp as an elderly murphy
speaks over a montage of dr brand
settling into her new home planet it's
meant to wrap up the entire film
and drive home the idea of moving
forward in our lives
but we're left wondering about the lack
of explanation at this key moment that
could have easily been remedied
by a single line about a debrief
although maybe that's a bit harsh
interstellar's plot does cover over 80
earth years a wormhole a black hole and
countless light years after all so
considering the circumstances we can
find it in our hearts
to overlook some omitted information
it's what cooper would do
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]